[Musik]
am 22 september 2017 gab es zwei
jubiläen zu feiern
80 jahre fliegerhorst in aigen im
ennstal und 50 jahre alt drei im
bundesheer viele gratulanten ehrengäste
und besucher wohnten den feierlichkeiten
bei die alle drei die maschine die sich
hinten sehen genau diese maschine war
die erste der drei die vor 50 jahren im
jänner 19 67 ihren dienst bei den
luftstreitkräften aufgenommen hat seit
19 37 ist der fliegerhorst in verwendung
1967 erhielt er den namen viel fern
druck nach dem erfolgreichsten feld
piloten der ehemaligen k & k luftdruck
über leuten und benno ritter von fern
druck die ersten vier alu matt drei
helikopter kann man 1967 nach österreich
heute wäre um 22 stück von den
luftstreitkräften betrieben statische
und dynamische vorführungen bei argo
hubschrauber und eine präsentation von
luftfahrzeugen nationaler und
internationaler gäste boten den
zuschauern ein spektakuläres programm
[Applaus]